good morning hi it's Tuesday so 1.6
million people will die of tuberculosis
this year more than will die of malaria
and HIV combined which is especially
infuriating because tuberculosis is
curable and there's a company you've
probably never heard of called danaher
that over the next 10 years has the
opportunity to save hundreds of
thousands of lives and I'd like all of
us to encourage them to take that
opportunity so tuberculosis has killed
over a billion people in the last 200
years and we've made very little
progress in ending it because both
testing and treatment remain Out Of
Reach for Millions like this year of the
10 million people who will get sick with
TB about 4 million people will go
undiagnosed often dying before they can
get an accurate test and among those who
do get diagnosed most are still
diagnosed via a person looking through a
microscope at a sputum sample which is
precisely how we diagnose tuberculosis
130 years ago there are two big
downsides to the microscope method first
it misses more than 50% of cases
especially in young children and imuno
compromised people and second even if it
finds TB microscopy can't tell you
whether a case is resistant to
antibiotics which means that many people
end up on the wrong treatment regimen
and commonly die before they can get on
the right one now I know what you're
thinking gosh I wish we had a
miraculously fast and accurate test that
could tell people not only whether they
have TB but which drugs their TB will
respond to so we could immediately begin
Curative treatment well good news we do
it's called the gene expert machine and
it is incredible it's made by a company
called seid that's owned by a larger
company danaher that also owns lots of
other companies and this Gene expert
machine can test not just for TV but
also for HIV coid and many many other
diseases everywhere I've traveled in
high TB burden countries people sing the
Praises of this incredible Gene expert
machine I mean within an hour you can
tell someone whether they have TB and
also what course of treatment will cure
their TB incredible amazing wondrous
thank you seied for building this
machine thank you danaher for making it
all happen there's just one problem as a
labtech and sier Leone very succinctly
explained to me the machine is amazing
if only we could afford the tests which
brings us to the printer Inc business
model now you may know that inkjet
printers are often sold at a very low
profit margin because that's not
actually how the companies make their
money they make their money by selling
ink once you're locked into a printer
often ink that you can't buy from
anywhere else the same business model is
used in disposable razor blades and also
Nespresso like take over the coffee
Market with inexpensive machines and
then price gouge on the Nespresso pods
and that is what danaher does with TB
test and that's not like my conclusion
their CEO rer Blair literally said these
are razor blade business models in
Mission critical applications which
sounds to me like the they're bragging
to their shareholders about ripping off
the world's poorest people okay so danur
currently charges $10 for each of these
cartridges which can detect TB and also
test for resistance to a common
firstline antibiotic and they also make
another cartridge that tests for
resistance to four more anti-tb drugs
for that one they charge not $10 but
$15 which is frustrating because one we
really need to identify extensively drug
resistant tuberculosis quickly and
accurately to prevent its further spread
and also two it doesn't cost danah her
more to make those cartridges than the
regular ones all the cartridges cost
them about the same to make so how much
should these cartridges cost well danah
her has refused to share any of their
cost information with global Health
authorities but in 2019 Doctors Without
Borders commissioned a study asking a
group to look at how much it cost to
make these and what they found is that
it cost somewhere between $3 and $4 50
the same is true for all of danah her's
test cartridges regardless of whether
they're testing for TB or xdr TB or HIV
or anything else based on that study
danaher is charging at least a 220%
profit margin for their regular TV
cartridges and closer to a 500% profit
margin for their extensively drug
resistant cartridges which in my opinion
is just unconscionable and I apologize
if I sound angry but I've known so many
people who went undiagnosed for months
or even for years and some of those
people have died and so I am angry they
died because they couldn't get an
accurate test in time and I simply don't
believe that Dan or her charging these
profit margins is making it easier for
anyone who needs the test to be able to
access it instead they are overcharging
poor countries for tests and preventing
competition by locking people into their
machines with that printer ink business
model they love to boast about also in
developing these tests danaher received
over 200 $50 million of Public Funding
most of which came from taxpayers like
me and and you and I think it's Pastime
for danaher's prices to acknowledge that
Gene expert tests are public goods
largely funded by the public and that it
isn't appropriate to use them to enrich
the world's richest people at the
expense of the world's poorest ones
since 2019 Partners in Health Doctors
Without Borders and a huge array of
other organizations have been trying to
convince Dan her to consider lowering
their prices to $5 per test cartridge
which would be a healthy profit margin
instead of an obscene one they've
written open and closed letters Sephia
and danaher haven't responded they've
lobbied for $5 tests in public meetings
Sephia and danaher haven't responded and
so now they've asked us to join them in
taking the next step on that Journey now
look danaher is a company with $8
billion in profit they are not hurting
but it's a little hard to put pressure
on them because they they don't own a
lot of consumer facing stuff although
they do weirdly own of all things
Pantone the color matching company
they're currently in the process of
spinning it off into another company but
Dan and her shareholders will still be
panone shareholders so maybe there's
some pressure to apply there but mostly
I think it's important for danah her to
know that this is just a bad business
decision it's important for them to know
that we are paying attention and will
continue to pay attention and we will
endeavor to make it cost more to their
reput utation and their ability to
recruit and do business then the infimal
hit to their profit that would accompany
$5 tests so that's where you come in if
you have 5 minutes to make a phone call
or write an email there are links below
and in the pinned comment also please
let danah her know on social media that
you will not accept this Injustice
they're on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram and threads and Hank and I
will be in all of those places
amplifying your messages and if you
happen to work at seied which makes the
cartridges or danaher which makes the
decisions let your bosses know that
you're not okay with this I know that
takes a lot of guts but I also know it
was an essential part of the pressure on
Johnson and Johnson that led to them
swiftly announcing they would allow
generic competition for their drug
bedine lowering the prices of these
tests to $5 would likely save hundreds
of thousands of lives over the next 10
years and I am disappointed that danaher
is currently choosing profits over
people but I I don't think it's
inevitable I think that most people most
of the time want to do what is right
they just sometimes need polite but
impassioned reminders of what's right I
know that I've benefited from those
polite but impassioned reminders from
others even when they've made me
uncomfortable and I believe that sethia
danaher and their Executives will
similarly benefit from your polite but
impassioned reminders finally a message
to danaher exx you've built something
amazing with the gene expert machine but
building something is only valuable if
the people who need it most can access
it right now you're falling short on
that front because the people who most
desperately need your tests often can't
get them and that results too often in
them dying it's time for $5 tests and
it's time to put people over profits
Hank I'll see you in comments on social
media in danaher's inboxes and their
phone lines and then I'll see you on
Friday